ja sehr geehrte damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsminister rintanen miliz
beauftragten hannes eder dem
generalstabschef brigger frau ministerin
bitte schon sehr geehrte generäle sehr
geehrte damen und herren die aktuelle
lage im zusammenhang mit dem corona
virus zeigt die einsatzfelder werden
mehr die anforderungen an das heer
werden größer
aktuell sind wir mit rund 3200
soldatinnen und soldaten im in und
ausland im einsatz
denn auch in zeiten von corona müssen ja
unsere bisherigen engagements weiter
laufen das heißt unsere verpflichtungen
in den diversen einsätzen vom westbalkan
bis nach wahl sowie der assistenzeinsatz
migration laufen weiter wir sind hier in
der steiermark in kärnten in tirol und
im burgenland im einsatz
besonders gefordert aber sind wir als
österreichisches bundesheer nun aber
beim coroner einsatz um hier weist das
aufgabenfeld ein besonders heterogenes
bild auf wir unterstützen zb in tirol
beim reisemanagement und beim fieber
messen
unsere soldaten sind dort nur schwer zu
erkennen weil diese ja auch weiße
schutzanzüge tragen des weiteren ist
auch eine jäger kompanie hier im raum
ist im einsatz und unterstützt auch bei
sicherheitspolitischen
sicherheitspolizeilichen aufgaben in
kärnten unterstützen wir beim
reisemanagement in salzburg mit einer
jäger kompanie des jägerbataillons 18
der sicherheitspolizeilichen aufgaben
und auch ein militärarzt ist hier im
einsatz und unterstützt das ärzte-team
im krankenhaus in salzburg in der
steiermark unterstützen wir die
gesundheitsbehörden an den
grenzübergängen sowie auch dem betrieb
des klinikums in graz wir unterstützen
personell die hotlines sowohl des
außenministeriums als auch der
und auch der landeswarnzentrale zum
beispiel in vorarlberg weitere
unterstützungsleistungen die wir als
österreichisches bundesheer tätigen sind
bei den supermarktketten bei der
lebensmittelversorgung der bevölkerung
derzeit mit noch rund 500 mann
wir haben seit vergangener woche
erwarten wir auch die botschaften in
wien um hier die exekutive personell zu
entlasten
sie sehen also anhand dieser vielen
beispiele einmal mehr unser heer ist in
krisen einsatzfähig abseits dessen
verlässt man sich aber auch länder und
ressort übergreifend auf unsere
kompetenz und auf unser know how
deutlich wird dass gerade in diesen
stunden denn heute nachmittag landen
zwei maschinen in schwechat die
insgesamt 130 tonnen ein notwendiger
schutzausrüstung direkt aus china nach
österreich bringen
dieser transport heute von uns
verhandelt und organisiert und ich
möchte an dieser stelle ein ganz großes
dankeschön an unseren generalsekretär
magistrat etat kandlhofer aussprechen
der sofort gehandelt hat entschlossen
und federführend dann auch diesen erfolg
des projektes möglich gemacht hat ich
möchte an dieser stelle aber auch allen
soldatinnen und soldaten sowie den
zivilbediensteten unseres ressorts danke
sagen die im einsatz sind insbesondere
am heutigen tag und bei dieser
pressekonferenz bei jenen reservisten
und milizsoldaten die uns kontaktiert
haben und ihre einsatzbereitschaft
kundgetan haben wir haben ja bereits
angekündigt
wir planen erstmals in der geschichte
der zweiten republik in einer situation
wie auch erstmalig und einmalig in der
zweiten republik da ist eine aufbietung
der miliz durchzuführen
geplant ist dass wir die
miliz im mai einberufen um die
verlängerten grundwehrdiener und
berufssoldaten die im einsatz stehen
ablösen zu können
hierbei sollen bis zu 3000 männer und
frauen einberufen werden
ich möchte an dieser stelle drei
botschaften an die miliz soldatinnen und
soldaten und auch an die wirtschaft
richten
erstens wir werden laut geplantem soll
stand rund 10 der miliz soldatinnen und
soldaten einberufen
zweitens die einberufungsbefehl werden
noch im april zugestellt und die
soldatinnen und soldaten werden ab dem 4
mai in dienst gestellt drittens es
werden nur jäger kompanien einberufen
keine ganze bataillone warum daraus
folgt auch dass kein arzt keine ärztin
einberufen wird denn auf company ebene
gibt es derzeit keine beorderten ärzte
ziel ist es nämlich dass wir
systemrelevante mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter kritischer infrastrukturen
natürlich nicht aus ihrem zivilen
funktionen ziehen wollen
es handelt sich bei den geplanten
einsätzen dieser miliz teile
größtenteils so gehen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt in unseren planungen davon aus
um sicherheitspolizeiliche einsätze das
bedeutet auch dass sich die soldatinnen
und soldaten am beginn ihres einsatzes
für circa zwei wochen eine
auffrischenden ausbildung unterziehen
werden bei der grundlegende und
sicherheits polizeilich relevante
fertigkeiten aufgefrischt werden sollen
abschließend ein appell ein ganz großes
dankeschön an all diejenigen die sich
schon bei uns bezüglich der einberufung
gemeldet haben sollten sie betroffen
sein so wird die einberufung wie schon
erwähnt rechtzeitig erfolgen und sie
erreichen
im hintergrund läuft aktuell
nach plan und hypo fest in unserem
ressort und darüber hinaus mit unserem
miliz beauftragten arbeiten auf
hochtouren
an dieser erstmaligen aufbietung der
miliz sollte eine die eine oder andere
frage zu diesem thema noch sein dann
bitte ich auch an dieser stelle wieder
nehmen sie kontakt mit unserer hotline
auf 0 50 201 ich danke ihnen bleiben sie
gesund dank pro minister miliz braucht
daher bitte schon sehr verehrte frau
bundesminister geschätzter herr general
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
gerade in zeiten einer krise wird sehr
deutlich werde ich wichtige funktion das
österreichische bundesheer hat zum
schutz unseres landes der bevölkerung
und damit auch der wirtschaft und wie
breit gefächert die einsatzaufgaben sind
schutz und hilfe ist das motto des
österreichischen bundesheeres und genau
um das geht es jetzt auch wenn wir
unsere miliz soldatinnen und soldaten
rufen das militär miliz ist das rückgrat
und damit auch der garant für die
durchhaltefähigkeit des österreichischen
bundesheeres
es geht darum so wie die von
bundesminister schon aus geführt hat zu
verstärken und die belastung im einsatz
für österreich auf breitere schultern um
zu leben
im jahr 2013 haben die österreicherinnen
und österreicher eine sehr klare
entscheidung getroffen nämlich eine
entscheidung für die wehrpflicht und
damit auch für die milito mit der
verfassungsrechtlichen verankerung des
milizsystems sind wir bestens
aufgestellt und nahe an der bevölkerung
der bürger in uniform mit all seinen
kenntnissen mit seinen fähigkeiten ist
somit das bindeglied in die gesellschaft
in die wirtschaft und von dort zum
österreichischen bundesheer und dieser
bürger in uniform ist jetzt gefragt als
melitta auftrag des österreichischen
bundesheeres darf ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal einige eckpunkte erwähnen
die für die wirtschaft und für die
milizsoldaten besonders wichtig sind die
ausbeutung der miliz ist in
professioneller vorbereitung und läuft
sehr ruhiger das ist ja wichtig diese
botschaft an die wirtschaft zu geben
am vierten mai werden dann bis zu 3000
soldaten aufgeboten und dann führt die
hilfe der menschen in österreich zur
verfügung stehen
spätestens bis 10 april ist klar welche
einheiten welche kompanien zum einsatz
kommen werden
es ist also damit genügend zeit für die
milizsoldaten aber auch für die
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer sich
organisatorisch darauf einzustellen
die milizsoldaten haben damit genauso
wie ihre arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber planungssicherheit
zur relation noch einmal die zahl jener
mit zutaten die aufgeboten werden
beträgt 3.000 das wurde von der frau
bundesminister gesagt und das entspricht
ungefähr zehn prozent der gesamten miliz
somit überschaubar und besonders wichtig
auch für die wirtschaft verkraftbar
diese 3000 personen kommen ja aus gesamt
österreich und die aufbietung verteilt
sich daher auch auf alle neuen
bundesländer und sollten damit auch
einzelne unternehmungen nicht über
gebühr belasten
ich weiß dass in der wirtschaft und bei
den unternehmerinnen und unternehmern
viel verständnis für die einberufung
von ihrem personal gegen den einsatz des
corona virus besteht und das ist auch
eine ganz entscheidende unterstützung
für die milizsoldaten das zu wissen denn
es braucht niemand angst um seinen
eigenen job zu haben und dafür möchte
ich jetzt schon ein herzliches
dankeschön an die unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer richten und sagen wir
orientieren uns alle gemeinsam an einem
ziel und das für die wirtschaft ganz
ganz wichtig es geht um den schutz der
österreichischen bevölkerung und dafür
sind unsere milizsoldaten bestens
trainiert vorbereitet und sie sind
hochmotiviert und damit auch bereit alle
gestellten aufträge zu erfüllen und
davon konnte ich mich in der
vergangenheit immer wieder auch bei
truppenbesuchen überzeugen ich bedanke
mich daher bei allen mit soldatinnen und
soldaten die in den einsatz gehen werden
dass sie nicht nur bereit sind das zu
tun sondern dass sie hoch motiviert ihre
funktion übernehmen werden und ich
appelliere an alle unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer diesen einsatz zu
unterstützen ja wert zu schätzen ihre
betroffenen mitarbeiter leisten einen
unverzichtbaren hohen sozialen aber auch
einen beitrag für die gesellschaft und
damit für die wirtschaft
und sie bringen all jene erfahrungen die
sie aus der wirtschaft haben in das
bundesheer für ihren einsatz mit ein
damit ist das ein unglaublich großer
mehrwert insgesamt geist auch die
funktionsfähigkeit unserer wirtschaft
bedeutet auch standortsicherheit
bedeutet versorgungssicherheit für
unsere gesellschaft und all diese
faktoren werden mit hilfe des dienstes
des österreichischen bundesheeres und
damit der miliz sichergestellt und
gesichert
ich selbst
komme aus der wirtschaft und bin
verantwortungsträger für banken und
verschiedene unternehmungen und ich kann
ihnen versichern dass wir unsere
milizsoldaten und soldaten auch in der
vergangenheit intensiv unterstützt haben
und wie sie auch jetzt massiv
unterstützen werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
unsere soldaten sind soldaten aus der
bevölkerung für die bevölkerung und sie
stehen für den vorgesehenen einsatz für
österreich höchst motiviert bereit
vielen dank dankeschön der
generalstabschef bitteschön frau
bundesminister sehr geschätzte damen und
herren in ausnahmesituationen ist ist
die aufgabe des österreichischen
bundesheeres durchhaltefähig zu bleiben
und die bevölkerung bestmöglich zu
unterstützen
wie wird das gemacht unabhängig von den
3000 soldaten die wir jetzt schon in und
ausland im einsatz haben sind
zusätzliche kräfte erforderlich
die bundesregierung hat sich daher
entschlossen einen aufschub des
präsenzdienstes zu erwirken und jene
soldaten die ende märz abgerüstet werden
länger im dienst zu belassen
diese soldaten werden mit dem mai
abgelöst durch die
schon mehrfach erwähnten miliz kräfte
miliz und präsenz stand wirkliche
synergetisch zusammen die präsenzkräfte
werden also zunächst die hauptlast
dieser assistenzen zu tragen haben
unterstützung im sicherheitspolizeiliche
hinsicht aber auch im
katastropheneinsatz um den
verbindungsdienst 'nen wo immer
militärischer support erforderlich ist
mitte mai werden die dann innerhalb von
14 tagen ausgebildeten miliz kräfte die
ablöse vollziehen und für einen weiteren
längeren zeitraum von etwa drei monaten
für diese aufgaben zur verfügung stehen
es ist somit über einen überschaubaren
zeitraum sichergestellt dass einerseits
der exekutive aber auch der verwaltung
und der bevölkerung insgesamt ein
wirksamer schutz und eine wirksame hilfe
durch das österreichische bundesheer zu
teilen wird die frau bundesminister hat
auch den historischen augenblick
gewürdigt eine auf witterung teil
aufbietung der miliz erstmals in der
zweiten republik zu vollziehen
ich bin der bundesregierung und der frau
bundesminister überaus dankbar dass
diese gelegenheit ergriffen wird weil es
in der geschichte der zweiten republik
schon mehrfach situationen gab wovon
militärischer seite eine solche
aufbietung wünschenswert und
empfehlenswert war nunmehr wir diese
gelegenheit ergriffen und das ist die
aufgabe der militärischen experten sind
bestmöglich zu nutzen erfahrungen zu
sammeln und alle ressourcen zum schutz
der bevölkerung und zur bewältigung
dieser ja doch einmaligen krise
entsprechend einzusetzen vielen dank
herzlichen dank bekommen jetzt umfragen
teil zuerst der orf bitteschön eine eine
verständnis frage dazu habe ich sie
richtig verstanden dass dann praktisch
diesen milizsoldaten ab juni im einsatz
sehen wenn sie mitte mai kommen und dann
1 214 woche 14 tage ausbildung haben
dann sind sie ab juni im einsatz ist das
so und dann hätte ich noch eine frage an
die frau minister
die aufbietung der miliz wird anfang mai
erfolgen
der einlösungstag wird voraussichtlich
der vierte mai sein
sodann 14 tage schulung und training
sodass sie mit 18 neuen präsenzkräfte
ablösen können
eine andere frage diese schutzausrüstung
die sie erwähnt haben die jetzt kommt
mit hilfe des bundesheers die wird jetzt
dann wie verteilt also wo kommt die hin
und wird da das bundesheer auch
unterstützend tätig sein
wie schon gesagt wir sind sehr dankbar
wie schnell über unseren generalsekretär
die organisation dieser beiden flüge
auch unter dieser beiden maschinen auch
unter mithilfe des außenministeriums
funktioniert hat das heißt die wahl zum
einen aufgrund der erfahrung
organisatorisch und logistisch tätig und
es wird jetzt auch dann notwendig sein
wenn jetzt in voraussichtlich zwei
stunden
diese beiden maschinen landen dass die
dann auch umgeladen werden in zivile
lkws und dann auch begleitet werden
nachdem momentan am stärksten
betroffenen gebiete das ist tirol und
das ist südtirol
wir gehen davon aus beziehungsweise die
gesundheitsbehörden gehen davon aus dass
mit diesen beiden lieferungen ist der
erste ganz dringend notwendige bedarf an
schutzausrüstung gedeckt ist
also wie gesagt 3000 soldaten und
soldatinnen werden da herangezogen circa
zehn prozent seien es von der miliz am
vielleicht nochmal nach welchen
kriterien werden dann diese soldaten und
soldatinnen ausgewählt wird da
vorgegangen
und nochmal zu diesem zeitrahmen dass
die dann ab dem 18
glaube ich habe sie gesagt mal wirklich
im einsatz sind ist dass die
schnellstmögliche variante also geht das
gar nicht schneller dass diese menschen
schnell im einsatz ist das genauso
getimt dass die dann die grundwehrdiener
ablösen ging es theoretisch auch
schneller
vielleicht darf ich bevor ich zu den
details der chef des generalstabs bieten
würde eines sagen alle unsere einsätze
die des österreichischen bundesheers
werden immer strukturiert geplant und
dann auch durchgeführt daher auch genau
diese abfolge und die von der
bundesregierung ist er generalstabschef
schon angesprochen hat notwendigen
maßnahmen sind ein zum einen die
verlängerung des grundwehrdienstes für
diejenigen die in den märz abreißen
würden und jetzt dann die ausbildung der
miliz um eines zu sichern nämlich die
durchhaltefähigkeit des österreichischen
bundesheeres für die vielfältigen
aufgaben
wir gehen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt davon
aus dass das für die miliz vorwiegend
sicherheitspolizeiliche aufgaben sein
werden und da eben auch diese
zweiwöchige auffrischung sozusagen
notwendig ist ja generalstabschef wenn
sie weitere konkrete ausführungen dazu
noch mal gerne es ist ja die aufbietung
grundsätzlich ein instrument der
militärischen landesverteidigung die
möglichkeit jetzt zunächst kräfte
einzusetzen die durch den aufschub des
präsenzdienstes verfügbar sind gibt die
möglichkeit einer längeren
durchhaltefähigkeit um die frage konkret
zu beantworten es wäre natürlich möglich
die miliz auch früher aufzubieten
mit etwa einen bis zwei brücken muss es
ist aber nicht erforderlich weil die
präsenzkräfte bis mitte mai die
entsprechenden sicherheitspolizeilichen
aufgaben erfüllen werden
auch gerne angefügt für uns ist das sehr
sehr wichtig und wir sind sehr sehr
dankbar dass dieser planungshorizont
gewählt wurde weil damit eben für alle
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
sichergestellt werden kann dass auch in
den betrieben das organisiert werden
kann und ordnungsgemäß unterstützend
durchgeführt werden kann
es wird gehen daran anschließend zehn
prozent der miliz kräfte werden
mobilisiert wie viele ressourcen hätte
man oh wie weit könnte man die die zahl
noch erhöhen ohne dass da jetzt die
wirtschaft darunter leiden würde weil
wichtige arbeitskräfte wechseln würden
dass sie sehen auch beurteilung des
generalstabs und dann der politischen
entscheidungsträger zehn prozent ist
eine klare ansage
da können sie feststellen es sind noch
90 prozent zur verfügung und wir alle
hoffen dass das also bei weitem so nicht
gebraucht werden wird sondern in der
regel wird es darum geht auch allfällige
weitere kräfte zur ablöse dann bereit zu
halten aber aus heutiger sicht werden
diese zehn prozent reichen und das kann
die wirtschaft sehr ordentlich auch
verkraften
darf der auftraggeber ist ja beim
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz die exekutive das heißt
ist richtet sich nach den erfordernissen
der exekutive und es wird dort
aufzubieten sein wo sich regionale
schwerpunkte abzeichnen wo eben eine
größere anzahl kritischer objekte zu
schützen ist zum beispiel also das wird
maßgeschneidert erfolgen dankeschöns tv
bitte möchten sich unter frage an das
was sie gesagt haben jetzt aber
anschließend alle militärs der welt
haben szenarien die sie entwerfen diese
überlegen und reagieren darauf
sie haben uns jetzt die reaktion
geschildert wie sie auf szenarien
reagieren wollen
sicherheitspolizeilichen dieser
kritische objekte schützen
wir sind die szenarien die das militär
bis ende mai
mit der juni ende juni hat er
grundsätzlich ist natürlich eine
pandemie immer ein aspekt militärischer
überlegungen gewesen das ist uns jetzt
so konkret trifft war für viele
überraschend war aber grundsätzlich
immer eine bedrohung der zu begegnen ist
und zwar einerseits natürlich durch
logistisch sanitätsdienstliche maßnahmen
aber der hauptaspekt liegt auf der
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz wo
eben kritische infrastruktur zu schützen
transporte zu gewährleisten und
letztlich die versorgung der bevölkerung
auch im falle von sicherheits
ereignissen entsprechend zu
gewährleisten ist es gibt keinen grund
zur annahme dass unruhen ausbrechen
sondern es ist eine präventivmaßnahme es
gibt auch keinen grund zur annahme dass
versorgungsengpässe unmittelbar
auftreten
aber diese kräfte sind für den fall
einer lage verschärfung verfügbar um die
polizei entsprechend zu entlasten um der
polizei auch die möglichkeit zu geben
die jetzt ja viel intensivere
überwachung des öffentlichen lebens
entsprechend durchführen zu können
danke schon jetzt kommen wir zur apa zu
eigenen fragen ab war und durch
dankenswerterweise die für die kollegen
die wie rung werk dabei sind bitte ich
habe bisher keine faden von außerhalb
gekommen
also habe ich mir es fehlen eben alle
orts- und sonstige schutz ausrichtung
sind die soldaten ausreichend geschützt
beziehungsweise wie sind sie geschützt
haben sie genug machten fehler 3000
soldaten
wir sind vorbereitet nicht nur was jetzt
die angesprochenen paar tausend soldaten
ambulanz selbstverständlich wird bei uns
auch in jeder kaserne dafür sorge
getragen dass den jeweiligen vorgaben
der gesundheitsbehörden auch folge
geleistet wird
da geht es um die frage des abstand
halten es da geht es um die information
darüber sich oft die hände zu waschen
wir sind selbstverständlich das habe ich
bei dem beispiel des grenze
einsatzes reisemanagement auch
angesprochen selbstverständlich mit
schutzkleidung für unsere soldatinnen
soldaten bei denen es gesundheitspolizei
ich auch notwendig ist beziehungsweise
gesundheits behördlich ausgestattet
ansonsten darüber hinaus wie schon
angesprochen haben wir gerade jetzt am
letzten wochenende auch dazu mit
beigetragen mit unserem besonderen
erfahrungen auch im logistikbereich und
das werden wir auch hinkünftig tun wenn
uns die gesundheitsbehörden dazu
anfordern
für den notwendigen auch nach super eben
von schutzausrüstungen zu sorgen dafür
sind wir da als die strategische reserve
der republik in jedem bereich immer wenn
es um anforderungen der exekutive geht
oder auch um anforderungen der
gesundheitsbehörden in andere frage es
gibt beim bundesheer auch verdachtsfälle
einige soldaten sind in quarantäne
können sie uns einen überblick darüber
geben wie viele soldaten betroffen sind
und wo sie sich befinden gibt es
erkrankte soldaten beißender schon
selbstverständlich einen überblick
darüber niemand ist in zeiten wie diesen
davor gefeit wenngleich man nur so viele
auch sicherheitsvorkehrungen trifft in
dem fall wird immer sofort gehandelt der
jeweilige soldat dann dementsprechend
auch in quarantäne je nach entscheidung
auch der gesundheitsbehörden gebracht
ich würde die zahle zahle jetzt nicht
der gerne nennen der generalstabschef
die aktuelle war glaube ich
berlin wo bereits entwarnung eingetreten
ist einige sind noch unter beobachtung
glücklicherweise bislang eine sehr
geringe anzahl nachdem der ganze
zeitplan für die milizsoldaten ja jetzt
schon über den sommer geht gehen sie
davon aus dass die lage noch eine
zeitlang kritisch bleiben wird oder ist
es jetzt eine reine vorsichtsmaßnahme
oder meint man dass die jetzt schon sehr
in im einsatz befindliche exekutive dann
in jedem fall eine entlastung braucht
also was ist da
der hintergrund praktisch der ganzen
maßnahme die er praktisch schon über den
ganzen sommer geht ja letztlich wird die
dauer des militärischen einsatz und der
assistenzen vom verlauf der epidemie
abhängen
ich glaube es ist im interesse jedermann
und jederfrau in österreich so rasch wie
möglich die normalität wieder einkehren
zu lassen jedoch zunächst ist die
sicherheit aller bürgerinnen und bürger
im vordergrund und daher wird es laufend
beurteilt von den sanitätsdienstlichen
behörden
es wird eine entsprechende beratung der
entscheidungsträger sichergestellt und
nach diesen fristen wird sich auch der
militärische einsatz richten
disziplinierter glaube ich die
österreicherinnen und österreicher sich
verhalten und die entsprechenden
abstände und auflagen berücksichtigen
desto rascher wir doch ein abflachen der
krise erfolgen und desto rascher können
auch militärische
unterstützungsmaßnahmen wieder
zurückgefahren werden
wenn die lage sich wieder normalisiert
kann es auch sein dass man die
milizsoldaten dann nicht mehr braucht
oder braucht man sie in jedem fall um
die exekutive nach dem langen ein dauer
einsatz zu entlasten das war das wird
die exekutive festlegen wie lange sie
unsere unterstützung bedarf
ich kann mir aber vorstellen dass wenn
eine entlastung eintritt dass dann auch
ein eine frühere entlassung der
milizsoldaten denkbar erscheint der
letzte frage von der apa sie haben
gesagt die auslandseinsätze laufen ganz
normal weiter wie ist die situation für
den auslands zutaten also gibt es eine
spezielle schutzmaßnahmen
beziehungsweise wie ist es mit heimat
urlaub und rückreisen müssen liedern in
quarantäne also was ist da angela es
sind die heimat urlaub sehr stark
eingeschränkt worden beziehungsweise
ausgesetzt
wir sind in der glücklichen lage
berichten zu können dass noch keine
bestätigten corona fälle bei den
auslands soldaten und soldatinnen
aufgetreten sind
selbstverständlich werden auch in den
auslands kontingenten die notwendigen
schutzmaßnahmen entsprechend befolgt und
umgesetzt
und daher wird auch bei den ablösung
sorge getragen dass die ablöse
kontingente von den abzulösenden
kontingenten entsprechend separiert
werden dass keine persönliche berührung
erfolgt und ein übertragungsrisiko damit
minimiert werden kann
gut dann sind wir soweit glaube ich
fertig den vielen dank für minister der
milizen auf der generalstabschef und
ihnen herzlichen dank fürs kommt man nun
für aufmerksamkeit